c'est une ville brumeuse de la région
d'auschwitz de cette fameuse pologne b
celle des petites communes ouvrière
catholique de campagne qui se sentent
parfois mise à l'écart de la
retentissante croissance économique du
pays
j'ai juste eu c'est aussi la ville
natale de la nouvelle première ministre
du parti droit et justice
béate un shido en a même été maire de
1998 à 2005
c'est auprès de ces régions que le parti
pis a agité la peur de l'immigration et
de l'islam
un discours qui a eu un écho plutôt
nuancé au sein de la population de
l'immigration ce n'est pas un problème
ici on accueille les gens ces gens qui
s'enfuit ce ne sont pas eux les fautifs
c'est parce qu'il ya la guerre dans leur
pays mais bien sûr on a peur on a peur
qu'il y ait des terroristes qui se
glisse parmi eux nous les polonais c'est
de ça dont on a le plus peur lui il a
changé de religion
il n'y a pas longtemps il a voté pour le
parti droit et justice qu'il a dans le
coeur mais c'est bien de changer c'est
bien pas brusquement évidemment il y
aller petit à petit mais il faut que ça
change
le changement c'est précisément pour
cela que la plupart des habitants de
cette région ont choisi le parti pis et
croit en ses promesses pour le charbon
qui fournit près de 90% de l'électricité
du pays
car ici tous les habitants où presque en
vivent
il y a un an les mineurs s'était révolté
contre l'ancien gouvernement qui avait
décidé de fermer quatre mines plus assez
rentable en tête de la contestation chez
gorz ici à la une du journal
ce père de famille a passé une semaine à
900 mètres sous la terre alors choisir
pis c'était donc aussi s'affirmer face à
une europe qui impose ses normes
climatiques notamment nous en tant que
mineur on a senti cette entrée dans
l'europe parce qu'on nous a imposé des
restrictions sur les volumes
d'extraction de charbon chaque
gouvernement nous dit que le charbon est
le socle de la pologne
c'est le slogan habituel mais jusqu'à
présent les politiques n'avaient pas
fait grand chose pour nous
le charbon socle de la pologne d'une
colonne qui se sont mis à l'écart par
l'europe
le parti droit et justice l'a bien
compris et a promis aux polonais de leur
redonner leur place au sein de l'union
c'est aussi ce que défend le directeur
de la mine d'objets j'te et élus du
parti pis dans la région il y a deux
tendances en pologne
ceux qui sont proches de l'europe et
ceux qui veulent cultiver leur polonité
et le pis a surfé sur cette dernière
tendance sur le fait qu'il faut cultiver
notre identité propre et défendre nos
intérêts nationaux
le discours de campagne du pis c'était
que l'europe défende est surtout les
intérêts allemands et français et qu'il
y a une division entre l'ancienne europe
des pays fondateurs et les nouveaux
venus de l'est
le pis a donc mis en avant le fait que
la pologne est le plus grand pays de la
région et que nous voulons avoir une
voix prépondérante au sein de l'europe
je crois que ç'a eu beaucoup d'impact
dans l'esprit des polonais
car nous sommes tous fiers notre origine
et de notre nationalité
et le vote peas n'a pas été circonscrits
aux campagne polonaise la nécessité de
changement s'est fait ressentir jusque
dans les grandes villes comme ici à
cracovie
le parti a renouvelé ses visages à
moderniser son ton et s'était adressé
pendant sa campagne à la jeune
génération
pour ces étudiants traditionnellement de
gauche pis avant tout été un choix
antisystème je vois parmi mes amis même
que
on n'avait pas vraiment le choix c'était
soit puisse latéraux et les gens étaient
si facile de perdre que beaucoup des
gens ont voté juste pour piste parce que
juste pour faire quelque chose c'est
qu'entre contre après les années de
communisme la pologne souffre dont
peut-être d'un renouvellement de l'offre
politique
pis a su en profiter et se faire élire
sur les frustrations des polonais la
volonté de changement la peur du chômage
et de l'immigration pour une pologne
profondément ancré dans lieu le vote si
ce n'est pas forcément animé par une
volonté de retour aux valeurs
traditionnelles mais c'est peut-être un
moyen pour les polonais de réaffirmer un
modèle national de l'europe